نجمه تلفزيون الواقع الامريكيه كيم
كارداشيان تصبح رمزا لسوء الحظ في عالم
كره القدم يقول كثيرون على مواقع التواصل
ان لدى كارداشيان لعنه فكلما ناصرت فريقا
وارتدت قميصه يخسر المباراه في النهايه
ولذلك قدمت صحيفه ماركا الاسبانيه نصيحه
لها بعد ارتباط اسمها بخساره فرق عده
قائلتان ان عليها اعاده قمصان كره القدم
الى خزانه ملابسها لفتره من الوقت لكن حتى
ان فعلت فصورها دائما ما تعود للظهور على
مواقع التواصل كلما خسر فريق شجعت في
السابق وهذا ما وقع مؤخرا بعد خساره نادي
روما الايطالي امام اشبيليه في نهائي
الدوري الاوروبي نفس السيناريو وقع مع
فريق ارسنال الانجليزيه الذي كانت تشجعه
كيم وفريق باريس سان جيرمان الذي سافرت
الى فرنسا لحضور مباراته في منافسات دور
الدرجه الاولى الفرنسي فهزم على ارضه ضد
فريق خلافا لجميع التوقعات